how long does it take to make money  it takes decades it's gonna take longer  than you would like but  uh you know the best time to start was  yesterday the second best time is now so  you may as well start if you're if it's  something you're thinking about  it's fine to start working on it now  and uh it may take a while for it to pay  out uh but when it does start paying out  you will essentially have  it's not that you will have made money  but you will have become the kind of  person that makes money and once you're  the kind of person that makes money and  you have some comfort around that then  you essentially have your freedom  so you're basically going to learn the  skills and how to make money you're  going to become a money making machine  and once you're a money making machine  the goal is that 10 or 20 years from now  that you will get hit by a tsunami of  money and you will know how it's coming  at you